over the weekend Roseanne Barr posted
and deleted 10 YouTube videos to her
channel mostly about her farm in Hawaii
but one of the videos titled the word F
is hateful I put the cue in LGBTQ
stirred up controversy Roseanne
controversial no way in the video
Roseanne admits that the word is hateful
but seems to get upset at who can use
the slur and who can't the word guys are
really hateful word what your oh I just
can't say the word well I can when I'm
in the house but I can't say it outside
of the house okay get your rules but it
is a hateful word you should get rid of
it get rid of it being spoken Roseanne
there are no rules you shouldn't be
speaking the word period nobody should
ever and the rest of the video Roseanne
goes on to call herself an alien and
says she identifies as queer all that
LGBTQ stuff okay let me just be real I
put the cue in LGBTQ okay cuz I am queer
as to [ __ ] I'm queer
I'm alien I don't belong here with all
these people we probably should mention
that rose in in the past has championed
equality and diversity for example in
1994 there was an episode of Roseanne
called Don't Ask Don't Tell which
feature Rose in kissing another woman
the episode was watched by more than 30
million people and she fought ABC to air
it besides I kiss Roseanne featured many
LGBTQ and racially charged storylines
hey black people are just like us
they're every bit as good as us and any
people who don't think so is just a
bunch of banjo picking cousin date and
barefoot embarrassments to respectable
white trash like us 566 Roseanne seems
to have fallen down a rabbit hole and
hit her head from blaming those who
spoke out about their me to experiences
to pointing fingers at Michelle Obama
and Sara Gilbert for getting her fired
what was in needs to do is take
responsibility for her own actions and
in my opinion she does
to cram it so what do you think of
Roseann criticising who can and can't
use the f-word do you think Roseann
really identifies as queer are you still
able to watch old episodes of Roseann
and enjoy them let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]
you